je dis à à Fabrice voilà on va faire une
scène de provoque comme ça qui fait que
on va sentir que les couples ont envie
de s'échanger
tout à fait bouffer des clous à Michel
Morgan j'ai vu
comment font tourner le chien et la
souris j'avais besoin un moment donné
d'un d'un moment de spontanéité comme ça
et on avait beaucoup de mal à la dérider
elle avait un petit peu le trac de cette
scène et donc je lui ai mis un clou dans
un gâteau
une réaction je savais même pas ce que
je voulais d'ailleurs je ce que je
voulais c'était la déstabiliser parce
que et donc j'ai fait mettre dans le
gâteau puisque on était au dessert j'ai
fait mettre un clou un vrai clou c'est
pratique de l'avoir à la maison d'accord
et au moment du tournage donc on donne
elle commence à manger le gâteau
évidemment elle tombe sur le clou
j'avais très très peur qu'elle se blesse
et elle a fait une fête elle a fait une
scène d'anthologie parce que elle est
partie d'un fou rire absolument
incroyable elle a très très vite compris
que c'était un clou qui avait été mis
par mois et elle est partie sur un fou
rire et c'est vrai que ce fou rire est
absolument magique après on a refait la
même scène avec le cloucy avec le clown
voilà et donc encore une fois ce soir là
on a vu à quel point l'as spontanéité
c'est
fameux parfums de vérité quand il dit ça
parce qu'après les gens qui entendent ça
au premier degré tu sais ils disent oh
mais les films de de Claude quand c'est
génial c'est parce que c'est improvisé
parce que il y a des acteurs géniaux et
ça ça me rend folle parce qu'en fait
c'est pas du tout comme ça je veux dire
derrière
c'est dans quel film sous la tente là
c'est énorme il a tourné avec moi il
sait très bien qu'il y a les figures
imposées il y a les figures libres
en train de diriger il manipule
que que Fabrice connaissait au cours de
circonstances encore une fois comme je
te disais tout à l'heure les choses ne
se passent jamais comme on les avait
imaginé voilà et donc à partir de cet
instant j'avais ce jour-là d'abord on
était très en avance et on avait deux
heures d'avance sur le planning on était
de bonne humeur on avait fait des belles
scènes donc il y avait une ambiance
formidable et moi je joue
essentiellement sur l'humeur des
comédiens dire que tous les matins je te
fais encore une petite parenthèse quand
j'arrive ce qui m'intéresse c'est de
savoir s'ils sont de bonnes ou de
mauvaise humeur et je vais faire avec
leur bonne et leur mauvaise humeur tu
peux pas empêcher les comédiens
d'arriver avec leurs valises et c'est
valide des fois elles sont bonnes des
fois elles sont pas bonnes ce jour-là
c'était impeccables il y avait une
humeur de chez moi incroyable sur le
plateau
et donc comment on avait deux heures
j'ai fait planter une tente dans un
garage de la maison au tournée parce
qu'elle est censée être
[Musique]
et je dis à Fabrice voilà on va faire
une scène de provoque comme ça qui fait
que on va sentir que les couples ont
envie de s'échanger étant donné qu'ils
sont à 4000 mètres
on va faire un peu des changements et je
lui dis en plus tu vas voir il y a
Uster qui est très bloqué il faut que tu
il faut que tu agresse Uster et plus tu
vas agresser Huster et Alex et plus on
va s'amuser et au moment de la
répétition je dis donc on fait une
répète et moi je savais que j'allais
tourner de toute façon la répétition et
tout le monde est persuadé que c'est la
répète et si la scène est réussie
évidemment que c'est grâce à Luchini
mais c'est peut-être grâce à Huster
parce que à un moment donné donc on
pense tout le monde pense que c'est une
répète et quand l'autre commence à
parler de turlutte de machin français
sort ton truc il y a eu terre qui se
prend un fou rire d'en faire et il se
dit si je reste face à la caméra je fous
la scène en l'air
a vu que la caméra tournée donc il a eu
l'intelligence de se retourner
d'être de dos à la caméra et Luchini
quand il a vu stère plongée il a fait
toute la scène pour Uster il avait envie
de l'écraser tu vois ce que je vais dire
donc il a joué tout sur Uster mais
Luchini est génial et il est énorme mais
à aucun moment il peut imaginer que la
scène sera dans le film et personne sur
le plateau pense sauf Huster qui me
connaît et qui sait que peut-être ça
sera dans le film donc Uster s'ouvre le
coup et en même temps ça lance le King
encore une fois je te dis parce que
c'est il avait déjà travaillé avec toi
donc oui ça va être clair Claude ce
qu'il dit pas parce qu'il est très très
modeste toujours mais il souffle bien
sûr derrière la caméra ce qui ce qu'il
appelle l'improvisation c'est toujours
une improvisation extrêmement dirigée
donc là ce soir on dit ensemble on a
tous une petite idée on se fait tous un
scénar avant de venir de ce qu'on va
dire de ce qu'on va pas dire de ce qu'on
va se raconter de ce qu'on va vivre mais
c'est vrai que
tous les dialogues qu'on a depuis le
début de cette soirée
moi je vais à aucun moment imaginer
qu'on partirait dans ces directions là
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu